Thank you. Thank everyone who come here for
this panel. So this panel is
really focusing on GLP-1s. We're going to talk about from mechanisms to
real evidence.
For that,
if I can remember,
the emerging role of GLP-1 in cancer prevention and outcomes.
We have three speakers. I'm Zhong Bian from Indiana University.
I'm going to chair the session. And then we have two wonderful
panelists.
The first
talk you're going to hear is from Dr.
Jennifer
Ligibel from Dana-Farber Cancer Institute at Harvard, and she's going to
talk about obesity and cancer, kind of the general theme, whether it's a
modifiable risk factor or not. And
then it's going to be followed by Dr.
Steve Hursting from
Lineberger Comprehensive Cancer Center at UNC, and
he's going to dig into more of the preclinical evidence
for the anti-cancer effects and the mechanism of GLP-1.
And I'm going to follow at the end, really just talk about some of the real-world
evidence on GLP-1
on cancer, both risk and outcomes, and some of the open questioning from
our studies. So let's welcome the first speaker, Dr.
Jennifer Ligibel.
Thank you all, and good morning. It's great to be here.
Thanks to the conference organizers for inviting me to kick off this
session on GLP-1s and cancer.
I'm going to talk a bit about obesity and whether this
is truly a modifiable risk factor for the development of cancer
or for cancer control after cancer is diagnosed.
Let's see here.
There we go. So we're going to start by reviewing some of the observational
evidence. Why are we even having a session today talking about weight loss
drugs and cancer? And then review the evidence that we
have looking at other strategies to manage weight,
lifestyle-based weight loss, bariatric surgery, and what we
know about these types of interventions and their potential
impact on an individual's risk of developing cancer
or their risk of dying from malignancy once cancer has been diagnosed.
So why obesity and cancer? We've known for a long
time that excess adiposity increases an
individual's risk of developing cancer.
It's been now more than a decade since Dr.
Hursting and I were part of this International Agency for Research in
Cancer effort to really summarize all of these data
looking at the relationship between excess adiposity,
whether measured by body mass index or body composition,
waist-hip ratio, and the risk of developing cancer.
Over the course of about 10 days, we reviewed more than 1,000 studies
looking at these relationships and found that there were more than a
dozen malignancies for which there was clear and consistent
evidence that as adiposity increased, so did the
risk of developing that malignancy.
And you can see from this list that there's a number of very common
cancers that are part of this obesity-cancer connection,
things like breast cancer and colon cancer, ovarian cancer.
As an oncologist, I focus specifically on breast cancer, and I'm going to talk a
bit about breast cancer throughout this session this morning because
this is really the place where a lot of these relationships between
obesity and cancer risk and outcomes really started.
And when thinking about breast cancer in particular, this
analysis through the International Agency for Research in Cancer found
that every five kilogram per meter squared increase
in body mass index, which is what takes somebody from normal weight
into overweight, overweight into obesity, each of those was
associated with a 10% increase in a woman's risk of
developing breast cancer after menopause.
So if you look at somebody of normal body weight, as you have increasing
levels of obesity, this starts to be a very important risk factor for
the development of breast cancer.
We also know that obesity continues to be very important even
after cancer has been diagnosed. This analysis
looked at the relationship between body mass
index and cancer outcomes in more than
six million individuals diagnosed with either an
early-stage or a later-stage malignancy.
In this analysis, the investigators found that across
all cancers, individuals with obesity had a
higher risk of all-cause mortality, had a higher
risk of cancer-specific mortality, and had a higher
risk of cancer recurrence compared to individuals diagnosed with
the same malignancies whose body mass index was in the normal
range.
Now, we know that obesity impacts some cancers more than others.
So the group then looked at the relationship between
obesity at the time of cancer diagnosis and
cancer-specific mortality across different malignancies.
They found, not surprisingly, that some of the strongest evidence that
increased adiposity, obesity at diagnosis was
associated with poor outcomes was seen in breast cancer.
And you can see that across 36 studies, obesity
was associated with more than a 20% increased
risk of cancer-related mortality in patients with breast
cancer.
The relationship between obesity and poor outcomes was also seen in
colorectal cancer, fewer studies, but very similar magnitude of
increase in risk, was also seen in pancreatic
cancer and in prostate cancer. So across these cancers,
obesity was linked to poor outcomes.Now, one thing about this
analysis was that it looked at patients with both earlier stage and later stage
disease. And the relationship between obesity and poor outcomes, I will
say, is much less clear in the setting of advanced disease.
And in fact, in some cancers, there has been this obesity paradox
where people who have more adiposity do better in the
setting of advanced disease, and some of that may be due to the fact that
people lose weight when they're quite sick with cancer.
Some of it may be some of this intriguing evidence that's arising about the
interaction between obesity and immunotherapy.
But it does make this analysis a little bit harder to untangle
in some cancers. And so that's why it was really, I think, very,
very important when last, about a year and a half ago, the
Oxford Overview Group looked specifically at the relationship
between obesity at diagnosis and recurrence
outcomes in patients with early-stage breast cancer to really look at
whether, giving us some more preliminary evidence, that
if you help somebody lose weight after they'd been diagnosed with an early-stage
malignancy, could you bend the trajectory of poor outcomes that
is seen in that group? And so this analysis looked at more
than 200,000 women who were taking part in clinical
trials of chemotherapy, radiation,
endocrine therapy. So these were all patients taking part in studies with highly
adjudicated cancer outcomes. A hundred and forty-seven different trials
were part of this analysis. And what the group found was that
each of those five-kilogram-per-meter-squared increases in body mass
index in these women was associated with a
6% increase specifically in the risk of distant disease
recurrence. They also found, very
interestingly, that this relationship was actually stronger in
younger women than older women. So this is very different than the
relationship between obesity and primary cancer risk.
In this analysis, although this increased risk of
specifically distant recurrence was seen in both younger and older
women and women with higher stage and lower stage disease,
where this absolute increase in risk was highest was younger
women with node-positive cancers.
So we don't really understand why the biology is so different when you're
looking at primary risk versus prognosis in early-stage
disease. But this has been seen not only in this analysis but also
others, very strong relationship between obesity and poor
outcomes in younger women with breast cancer.
The analysis went on to look at patients receiving different types of
therapy to see if perhaps the adverse effect of
obesity was related to endocrine signaling or if they
could try to untangle that. And they found, in fact, that poor outcomes were seen
across the board for patients who were treated with chemotherapy alone,
with endocrine therapy, or the combination.
And they also demonstrated that this relationship between obesity and poor outcomes
was seen in both hormone receptor-positive and hormone
receptor-negative cancer. So really, a very, very
broad spectrum of patients who are potentially at risk
of poor outcomes related to excess adiposity and
obesity.
So this really leads us to the central question that we hope to address today
through these three talks. Is obesity a modifiable risk
factor for cancer?
Unfortunately, we don't have much evidence at this point from well-designed
randomized trials looking at the impact of an intentional weight loss
intervention, whether that be lifestyle, drugs, or surgery
on the risk of developing or dying from cancer.
But there's some really intriguing evidence that has come from long-term
follow-up of bariatric surgery cohorts that suggest, in
fact, that if you help someone lose weight, you can actually reduce their risk
of developing cancer.
It's important to recognize that these are not randomized trials.
These are largely prospective cohorts where individuals who undergo
bariatric surgery are matched by age, BMI,
gender, and often comorbidity status with individuals who
don't undergo bariatric surgery, and then the two cohorts are followed
over time. This recent meta-analysis looked at 32
different cohort studies of bariatric surgery with matched
controls, more than 500,000 patients who underwent
surgery with 1.8 million matched controls.
Over the follow-up period, which did vary from study to study, there were
more than 95,000 total cancers diagnosed, and
41,000 of these were what we think of as obesity-related cancers.
You can see when looking at the relationship between bariatric
surgery and overall cancer risk that the individuals who
underwent bariatric surgery were at almost 40%
lower risk of developing any malignancy in the
follow-up period as compared to individuals who did not undergo
bariatric surgery. And although the numbers are a little bit
smaller when looking at obesity-related cancer, the
effect was actually even a little bit stronger, that individuals who
underwent bariatric surgery were at lower risk of developing
malignancy.
Now, as some of these cohorts have matured, we've been able to look not
only at overall cancer risk but also specifically at some of
the cancers which are most strongly related to obesity.
So this systematic review of intentional weight loss and cancer risk
included 18 studies, including primarily bariatric
surgery studies, but one lifestyle-based weight loss trial.
They demonstrated, first, a reduction in overall risk of malignancy
and, in particular, of obesity-related cancers.
But what I think is most interesting about this review was they were able to
look at the relationship between the development of
specific cancers and whether or not patients had taken part in
a weight loss intervention, largely surgery.
They found that some of the cancers most tightly related to
obesity were not surprisingly,
significantly reduced in risk in people who underwent
bariatric surgery. An up to 50% lower risk of breast
cancer, up to 60% lower risk of colorectal
cancer, a reduction in the risk of pancreatic cancer, which is quite
notable given our limited treatment strategies for this malignancy.
Endometrial cancer also significantly less likely in patients
who underwent bariatric surgery, and emerging evidence in many of
the other obesity-related
malignancies.Looking
into the bariatric surgery a little further, the picture becomes a little
bit more complex. And one of the studies that has contributed
probably the most to our understanding of obesity and cancer over
time has been, I'm sorry, of bariatric surgery and cancer
risk over time, has been the Swedish Obese Subjects study.
This study, although relatively modest in size, 2,000 patients who
underwent surgery matched with about 2,000 matched controls, the
follow-up time from this cohort is now more than 25
years in the bariatric surgery population and almost that in the
control group. And what they found interestingly is that
this relationship between bariatric surgery and subsequent cancer
risk, at least in this cohort, really seems to be seen
primarily amongst women as opposed to men.
This has been shown in some other cohorts as well, but
suggesting that this relationship does seem to
be somewhat gender dependent.
The other very interesting finding from this cohort has been
looking a little bit at metabolic dysfunction in
cancer risk, because we know that obesity,
BMI, is an imperfect marker of metabolic health.
And so another analysis from the Swedish Obesity study
has looked at the relationship between fasting insulin level
and this connection between bariatric surgery and
subsequent cancer risk. And what it shows is that patients who
have normal insulin resistance
at baseline do not seem to have the same difference in
risk of malignancy by bariatric surgery.
So as insulin resistance mounts, these two curves separating,
suggesting a larger potential benefit of bariatric
surgery in reducing subsequent cancer risk, which I think will be quite
interesting when we look later at some of the mechanisms of GLP-1s and
how they may impact long-term cancer risk.
So we've talked a lot about bariatric surgery, but recognizing that really
only a small number of people with obesity undergo
bariatric surgery. What do we know about other types of
weight loss? I'm going to specifically focus a little bit on
lifestyle-based weight loss, which we know generates a much smaller
degree of weight loss than either surgery or medication.
But there is some evidence that lifestyle-based weight loss could
impact an individual's risk of developing malignancy.
So this was an analysis from a pooling
project looking at studies of diet and in cancer that included more
than 180,000 post-menopausal women.
And they looked at the relationship between weight change over a 10-year
period and breast cancer risk. There were three measurements that were
taken of weight in this population.
Patients were considered having stable weight loss if they lost
weight during the first five-year period, and then they kept that off during the
second-year period. Conversely, if they gained weight in the first five
years and kept it and continued to gain weight, they were considered having weight
gain. There were almost 7,000 cancer cases that were
diagnosed over an eight-year period.
And what they found was that sustained weight loss achieved through
lifestyle means was associated with a lower risk of
developing breast cancer. And you can see here that this is a fairly linear
relationship. The individuals who successfully maintained weight
loss more than nine kilograms had about a 40% lower
risk of developing breast cancer.
So somewhat akin to what we've seen in some of the bariatric surgery studies.
As the weight loss was less pronounced, the reduction was also less
pronounced, but suggesting that perhaps this degree of weight loss
achieved through lifestyle could also have an impact on cancer risk.
There is one randomized study that also presents some tantalizing
data suggesting that a lifestyle-based weight loss program could reduce
the risk of developing cancer. This was not a study that
was designed to answer this question.
The Look AHEAD Study was actually a trial that enrolled individuals with
diabetes and looked at whether a structured lifestyle intervention
focused on weight loss could actually reduce the risk of cardiovascular
events in this population of individuals with type 2
diabetes. But cancer was a predefined secondary outcome,
and the intervention in this study was very effective at
inducing long-term weight loss. And you can see here that there was
significant weight loss of almost 10% over the first year.
And although that attenuated to more of a 4% to 6% weight loss over
time, it was sustained in the population of patients
randomized to the weight loss program.
And what they found after 11 years of median follow-up in almost
700 incident cancers was that there was no reduction in
overall cancer incidence, so very different than the bariatric surgery
literature, but about a 20% reduction in
obesity-related cancers. And whether that was statistically significant
or not depended on which list of obesity-related cancers that you
used. But I think some interesting preliminary evidence that this
degree of weight loss could have an impact on the risk of developing
cancer, perhaps not to the degree of the 40% weight
loss that's seen with bariatric surgery, but still a potentially meaningful
reduction in the risk of cancer. The study also looked in a very
exploratory way at individual malignancies.
Again, this was only 5,000 patients, but saw a trend toward a
reduction in pancreatic cancer and in post-menopausal breast
cancer. So a lot more to learn, but I think that we do
have some really interesting preliminary evidence suggesting that weight is
indeed a factor that we can modify and potentially
influence an individual's risk of developing cancer.
But what about cancer recurrence?
We have so much evidence, especially in breast cancer, that higher
levels of adiposity at diagnosis are linked to poor outcomes.
This is what led us to develop now, a decade ago, a phase three
trial that will evaluate whether
aSupervised, structured weight loss intervention
could reduce the risk of recurrence and improve survival in patients with
early breast cancer. The Breast Cancer Weight Loss Trial enrolled
3,180 women between
2016 and 2021 from more than 600
clinics across the United States and Canada.
Patients were eligible if they had been diagnosed with a Stage 2 to 3 breast
cancer and had a body mass index of at least 27
kilograms per meter squared. The patients were randomized one to
one to a two-year telephone-based weight loss program that was a
lifestyle program focused on caloric restriction and increased
physical activity, or to a health education control group.
Our primary outcome of this study looks at invasive disease-free
survival, and we are hoping to have these results within the next one
to two years. But in the meantime, have started to analyze a number of
our key secondary outcomes. The first of these was
published this year, and I'm going to just spend a second
talking about who these patients were.
So you can see, on average,
the average age at diagnosis and participation in this trial was
53.
At baseline, the average BMI was 34 kilograms per meter squared.
So patients were largely well into the range of obesity
during participation in this trial.
About 80% of patients were White, about 13% African
American, and about 7.5% of patients were Hispanic.
On average, there were 10 months between initial diagnosis and enrollment in
this study.
So the first secondary outcome that we've looked at is, was the
intervention successful in inducing weight loss?
You can't really study whether a
weight loss program improves outcomes if it doesn't actually impact patients'
weight. And so we published in JAMA Oncology last year that the
intervention group versus controls lost almost 6% of
baseline body weight at one year. We also demonstrated that
the proportion of patients who lost 5 and 10% of baseline
body weight was significantly greater in our intervention group, with almost
50% of patients losing at least 5% of baseline weight
and more than 20% losing more than 10% of baseline
weight. And that was compared to 12% and only
6% of control patients who met these weight loss goals.
We also have looked at some of the correlative science,
looking at the impact of the weight loss intervention on key
metabolic and inflammatory biomarkers.
These data were presented at the San Antonio Breast Cancer
Symposium and demonstrate that this degree
of weight loss that we saw in our intervention had a significant
impact on metabolic and inflammatory biomarkers.
We saw about a 21% reduction in fasting insulin at
six months that was largely maintained at 24 months.
We also looked at insulin resistance measured by HOMA.
And I just want to point out that at baseline, you see that both groups had a HOMA
score of more than four, which demonstrates a fairly high level of
baseline insulin resistance. We decreased this by
25% in the intervention versus control group at six months,
and although there was some attenuation of this at 24 months, still saw
a significant reduction in insulin resistance in patients randomized
to our weight loss intervention. We also looked at fasting
leptin and saw very similar reductions at
six and 24 months. And finally, we looked at
C-reactive protein as a general marker of inflammation.
And although the reductions were not numerically as large, we did see
significant reduction in our intervention group versus controls, which
interestingly, unlike the metabolic markers, became a bit more
significant over time as the intervention progressed further.
We will continue to follow these patients and again, hope to have more information
about the impact of this structured weight loss program on outcomes in early
breast cancer within the next year or so.
So in conclusion, I'm hopeful that this sets us up well for the rest
of our session focusing on GLP-1s.
We know that obesity is related to both an increased risk of
developing and dying from cancer.
Our preliminary evidence suggests that this is a modifiable risk factor.
If we can find a way to help patients lose weight and sustain weight loss,
we do definitely have the possibility of impacting their risk of
developing malignancy and the likelihood that they'll survive if they're
diagnosed with an early-stage cancer in particular.
Thank you so much for your attention.
I think we can take one or two questions if you have a direct question
about the presentation.
We do have 20 minutes at the end kind of reserved for a panel discussion,
but if you have an immediate question, please.
Thank you. Nice talk. Question about visceral obesity
and
the inflammation that people speculate is involved.
There is the thin patient who has visceral obesity,
and do you think we should be
switching to body composition assessments rather than just BMI?
I think that's an excellent question.
And actually,
as Steve may remember, with that International Agency for Research in Cancer
monograph that we put together, there was a day-long argument about what's
the right measure. I think we all recognize that body mass index
is easy and cheap, but it is not a very accurate
measure of metabolic health. I think it was really interesting to look
at the data from that Swedish obesity study showing that people who
have bariatric surgery generally are in--
you need to have a BMI of at least 30, but most of the time, the average BMI for
that procedure is in the 40s, and yet patients who
underwent bariatric surgery, even with those high BMIs, did not all have insulin
resistance. And in that study, there wasn't a benefit
of bariatric surgery in terms of cancer risk for patients who did not
have metabolic dysfunction. So I think your question is a great
one. I think what's hard is that the evidence that we have so far largely
comes from these large cohorts and these databases, and BMI
is easily available, but body composition is not.
And I do think that there is a lot that we lose by just
focusing on body mass index. And hopefully, as we move
forward, and especially thinking about what patients might actually benefit from
these types of prevention strategies, we're going to need to use something a
lot more precise than body mass index.
Most of the postmenopausal breast cancer patients are getting DEXA scans,
and it's the same machine can give the same information.
We just don't
do it in the clinics.
Right. You need kind of a different algorithm and program, and unfortunately, a lot
of clinics-- We went through this with the breast cancer weight loss study.
We really wanted to be able to look at body composition, and we
found that especially, many of the patients are treated in community
centers and they
don't have the ability. Even though it's the same machine, they don't have the
software, they don't have anyone to interpret it. But I agree.
Now there's much better data that comes from some of these
scales and things that used to be very poor quality
data, but there's been huge advances in the use of these
bioimpedance monitors that you find all over the place.
So I think that we are at a time when there is a lot more opportunity there, for
sure.
Maybe one more question, and then we can conclude.
Hi, very nice presentation. So my question is, I
was wondering, people with normal BMI,
how does that apply? So
weight loss in normal BMI will not have any
effect on cancer risk?
So that is a great question.
There are some studies that have suggested that people that are metabolically
unhealthy, even if they do have a normal body mass index, may
be at increased risk of developing malignancy, but there's a lot more that
we don't know. I do think that we need to think a little
bit about this
metabolic health and obesity and cancer risk.
There was a lot of excitement, for example, about the use of
metformin to potentially improve cancer outcomes,
and when you look at observational studies of individuals who were taking
metformin for diabetes, or it's not used as widely, but
sometimes for weight loss, there seemed to be this really strong signal
that that medication was linked to a lower risk of
developing breast cancer in particular, linked to better cancer outcomes.
But when this was studied in a phase three trial and the drug was given to normal
weight patients without any kind of metabolic dysfunction, the
drug did not have any beneficial effect at all in lowering cancer risk.
So I think we need to be careful and figure out when we think about
metabolic health, what are we really measuring and who are the
people that potentially might benefit that don't have outward
signs of obesity? I think that it would probably not be the best
strategy to be using some of these
medications for diabetes or weight loss in an unselected group of
patients with normal body mass index.
But we do need to figure out what are those metabolic markers that put normal
weight people at higher risk of these kind of obesity-related
cancers.
I'm wondering if this is related to the inflammatory cytokines,
because some people with normal BMI can have insulin resistance
too, right?
Exactly. I think that this is kind of an area of really
active research. Inflammation, certainly there are people that have kind of
the immune suppressive patterns that we see in individuals with obesity that are
normal weight, and we don't understand exactly why that is.
I think that there is this really important, and I know that
Dr. Hustings is going to talk about this too, but this interplay between
inflammation and metabolism and the immune system that is
impacted by obesity, but other things as well, and we need to kind of untangle that
as we think about which patients may be the best potential subjects
for these types of studies.
Great.
Thank you.
Thanks, Jennifer.
Thanks.
So, the next speaker will be
Dr. Steve Hustings, and he's going to actually present some of the
preclinical and mechanism data.
Well, thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
It's an honor to be here in beautiful San Diego and have a
chance to talk about preclinical studies related
to the
GLP-1 receptor agonists, particularly their effects and
mechanisms.
Jennifer, you did a great job of introducing this topic and
reviewing the obesity cancer link.
One other
initiative around the same time as the IARC was the
AICR/WCRF
Expert Report Series. It came really very
close
concordance with the IARC, using a very different
approach
for these obesity-related cancers.
And
I had the honor of being on this one as well, and one of the
major kind of calls for action from the
report was an urgent need for new strategies to
mitigate the impact of obesity on cancer.
Jennifer
described
certainly lifestyle and bariatric surgery.
So we'll talk about a different approach today.
And I'll focus on breast cancer, endometrial cancer, and colorectal
cancer in the preclinical work I'll describe.
But as Jennifer said, and this is our traditional kind of
strategy is a lifestyle-based, typically a
dietary approach that requires some form of calorie restriction to
induce weight loss. And as she said, for some, this can
be very effective at reducing weight and
reducing cancer risk. Very effective in animals.
There's a large literature about how effective--
Of course, animals follow what we
prescribe them. So
that's the challenge. It's difficult for most people to maintain, as
Jennifer indicated. It was the folks that could sustain this
reduction in weight where we're seeing effects.
Bariatric surgery, a stronger picture here, as Jennifer described,
but limitations here as well in terms of cost and
particularly very few, less than 1% of individuals with obesity
qualify for bariatric surgery.So that's likely not
the public health strategy to solve this obesity cancer
problem. So our question of the day is, do these
GLP-1 receptor agonists offer a scalable
solution for preventing or intercepting obesity-related cancers?
As we know, there's lots of ads on television for these, that
there's sort of two
flavors of GLP-1 receptors that have been approved for both type 2
diabetes and for weight loss. Semaglutide, which is a
single GLP-1 receptor agonist, and
tirzepatide, which is a dual GLP-1 receptor and
GIP receptor agonist,
very effective with weight loss.
Estimates are we're at about the 22% of
the adult population have
tried these drugs, and about 15% currently are
on these drugs. So the natural experiment is getting ahead of us a
bit. What is the impact on cancer is sort of the
question that we're trying to address today.
And so we turn to pre-clinical work.
We're going to hear from our chair that there is some epidemiologic
data.
But these newer drugs are only fairly recently
available and approved for weight loss.
So it's going to be a while before the epidemiologic data's really kind of clear,
as well as the clinical data. So I would argue that we can rely on
the
pre-clinical work to maybe get some early picture of
how these drugs are working and how effective they
are. So we asked the question, does tirzepatide,
the dual agonist, intercept obesity-driven mammary,
colon, and endometrial cancers? And we used this sort of
strategy for all three cancer types.
We took a group of C57 black 6 mice, had
a large cohort on a high-fat diet, induced obese diet for a
period. We also compared to a control group, a never
obese group that were on a low fat and so a lean
phenotype throughout the experiment.
Some of these mice we left on the obese diet all the way through, so
there's our sort of continuous obese group.
We randomized some of these to tirzepatide.
We had to come up with a regimen that mimicked that
20-ish percent body weight loss in humans,
and found a sort of dose escalation to do this.
And so we followed this protocol across three
different models. I think I'm showing here MC38 colon tumor, but we
also did
an EO771 breast and
an ER positive PY230 model.
This work we're working on, Nature Communications
reviewers have been very helpful and
with good suggestions, so we're working through that.
We did get a preprint out on this, sort of the early part of this work, and
this work's led by Dr. Ellie Glennie and Dr. Mike Coleman in the lab.
Before we get into the data, why tirzepatide? Why'd we pick that?
Well, it's the most effective of the FDA-approved drugs for weight
loss thus far. And
what convinced me was the SURMOUNT-1 trial, shown here, came out a couple of
years ago and contributed greatly to the approval of tirzepatide
for weight loss. And as you can see, at the two sort of
middle and higher dose, getting 20% weight loss on average
in this fairly large clinical trial.
What else does that? I mean, what else gets us into that 20% range besides
bariatric surgery?
So this was impressive and led to us
asking the question, well, what's the effect on cancer?
As I said, we first had to come up with this dose escalation sort of strategy,
as is done in humans.
Folks start at a lower dose and work their way up, primarily to avoid
some of the GI and other issues, side effects with that
drug.
But as you see, we managed to match that sort of
20% body weight that you see achieved in the human.
We also coupled this with some comparison groups.
So again, at a time when our continuous lean control
mice and our continuous obese mice were stable in
their either high or low weight, we randomized some of those
obese mice to a pair-fed group to the
tirzepatide. And so this allows us to look at what's the effect of
the sort of reduction in appetite and weight independent of
the drug itself. Of course, the tirzepatide here.
And we also compared it to a chronic calorie restriction group.
So this is, again, a well-established anti-cancer
intervention.
This is at a 30% reduction in calories, and you see actually mimic
the tirzepatide very well, but the restricted group
kept going in terms of their weight loss.
And they're not allowed to change their
eating patterns. So this is sort of our positive control.
This is how good we could get if we could get that kind of weight loss
is sort of the question here.
In terms of metabolic,
reversing some of the obesity-induced metabolic change, I'll point
to sort of the obese group here in the middle, and we see the
hyperglycemia that's induced by the obesity nicely
reversed by the tirzepatide, even more so with the calorie
restriction. Hyperinsulinemia also reversed.
You see
from a, oh, 50% increase to right back to the
control level.And hyperleptinemia, and that was the
big mover, about a 20-fold increase in leptin in the obese group that's largely
reversed with tirzepatide, and to a greater extent, the calorie
restriction. So tirzepatide successfully reversing the
obesity-induced metabolic perturbations that we know are
associated with cancer. What about tumor response?
Again, we started with the triple negative model,
E0771, across those five interventions, and we see
again the obesity bump up in tumor mass,
tirzepatide reducing that right back to the control level.
Interestingly, the pair feeding matched it really quite well,
so suggesting that maybe most of the effect of the
drug is on appetite and weight, not
necessarily a direct effect beyond that.
And again, the calorie restriction, very effective.
Almost undetectable tumors in most of those mice.
Similarly, with Erin Giles, who's in the audience,
we shipped up some tirzepatide, and she ran it through her
ER positive PY230 model and also saw a nice
reduction in
tumor growth in that model.
Similar effects were seen in collaboration with Vicki Bay
Jump, colleague at UNC and head of our gynecologic
oncology program,
in her model of endometrial cancer. We've got a genetic model here.
So we've done both sort of more of a prevention mode, where we start
the drug prior to development of tumors in these mice,
LKB1 p53 deficient mouse model, as well as after
tumors appear, and both were effective.
This is, in fact, the most responsive model in our hands.
Endometrium is the
most sensitive to obesity, so it kind of makes sense.
That was the one model where we actually saw a reduction even in non-obese
mice. So that model was even a slight
metabolic perturbation seems to be influencing that model, as well
as colon cancer. And I'll show more data on this MC38 model because
our immunologists at UNC love this model.
It's a
really immunologically hot model and
well characterized for its effects with immunotherapy.
So we'll see more data on this further.
But here, we found no evidence for direct effects on
cancer cells.
But I will say cancer cells seem to downregulate both GLP-1 and
GIP for the most part. When you look at cell lines, there's a cell
line encyclopedia,
that all those have been sequenced and very low expression
of both receptors in most
human cancer cell lines. Certainly, in our models, we didn't see receptor
active expression. And
across a large range of tirzepatide, we just see no
effects
on anything growth,
migration, metabolic, just flat.
So I don't think there's effects, at least in our models, directly on the
cancer cells. So we got looking at, well, what might
be underlying these anti-cancer effects?
And
so using multi-omic approaches, we started with bulk RNA sequencing
and gene set enrichment analysis.
And the leading edge was immune response, so the hallmark
immune response, and I'll show the data in a moment.
Second was metabolism, and they're both certainly linked in with cell cycle, which
was third.
But the immune response, obesity being highly immunosuppressive,
rescued by tirzepatide, was the story that kept coming out.
So what we found from the bulk, I'll just summarize, and I'll show you the data.
Obesity drives T cell immunosuppression, particularly.
This is reversed by the tirzepatide.
We also, thanks to the NACT Communication reviewers, we also
did single-cell sequencing and spectral flow cytometry.
And there it got more granular, backed up the
bulk seq, but allowed us to really show that obesity locks
CD8 positive T cells in a naive failure to launch
state,
and it hampers antigen presentation as well. So it's a kind of a double hit.
These T cells aren't able to respond
to the sort of activation signal from antigen
presentation, and the antigen presentation itself is down.
And both of these were rescued by the tirzepatide.
We've also done some 16S rRNA sequencing and metabolomics
in collaboration with Catherine Cook at Wake Forest,
and find that obesity drives gut microbial dysbiosis
that is reversible by several things that we're looking at with Catherine,
but including tirzepatide. And tirzepatide seems to
particularly enrich butyrate-producing bacteria, the short chain
fatty acid producing bacteria that's probably addressing some of the
inflammation of obesity. The paper actually just out
today, Catherine Cook being the lead author, showing the
obesity effect, and we've got a series of these, including tirzepatide, probably
later this summer. So the bulk RNA seq, this is one of
the most consistent stories we've found in both the MC38 and
E0771 model, particularly. We see this
suppressive effect of obesity across
under the immune hallmark, several pathways, several
gene sets related to the immune allograft
rejection all the way down,
kind of a consistent suppression.
The only exception was TNF-alpha signaling in the
obese that's rescued, that's completely reversed by the tirzepatide in
both models.
So this was a very clear-- That kind of consistency we don't always see, but
very clear picture that obesity drives an immunosuppressive
and inflammatory phenotype in tumors,
and that tirzepatide restores that anti-tumor
immunity.How does it do this? Well, it's a
story of TILS and TAMs, and so we'll get into that.
First, what are TILS and TAMs? Well, by TILS, I'm referring to CD8
positive T cells. These are those
kind of killer T cells that infiltrate tumors,
and then through a direct antigen-specific
manner, destroy tumor cells and control tumors.
So that's the TIL side. They do so by producing things like
perforin, granzymes, and interferon gamma.
So the
secretome of these cells is what really does the job.
And they kill directly by recognizing MHC class I on
tumor surfaces. And that's the TAM side of the
story, is that's the role that they play.
But they can be kind of double agents.
So we know that depending on metabolic state and other
factors,
these tumor-associated macrophages can either be anti-tumor,
we call those M1-like, there's even more granularity
developing in that area, or pro-tumor, and that's sort of the
M2-like class.
And so phagocytosis is what's kind of the hallmark of the
M1s.
So chewing up those cancer cells,
presenting antigen either directly to the
CD8 T cells or to professional antigen presentation
cells is sort of what they're doing.
But under certain conditions, again, obesity seems to be driving more of
the M2 TAM kind of phenotype. And
so that's getting in the way. The secretion changes
to growth factors like VEGF.
And so the M1s are helping activate the T cells,
but the M2 when they're in that state, actually
blocks activation. So
that's the TIL and TAM side.
So this orthogonal confirmation that we did really kind of revealed some of what's
going on here. I'm showing what's called a UMAP plot here.
This is of a spectral flow data just because there were fewer markers.
This is 17 immune markers. You can also do a UMAP
for the single-cell sequencing data, which gets a little more
complicated. But these pretty pictures, these UMAPs,
kind of display that sort of either differential gene expression, if it's the
sequencing data, or the differential state markers, if it's
the spectral flow data. And the UMAP
is a uniform manifold approximation and projection, which
that definition didn't help me very much.
But what it is, it's a way to visualize the high
dimensional data that's coming from these types of analyses, and it
allows you to group data based on either the differential gene
expression for the sequencing or the differential state marker
expression. And what we found is, under control
conditions, non-obese conditions,
here's representatives of both differential gene and
the differential state markers. Really surprisingly good
concordance between those two modalities.
CD44, granzyme B, PD-1, TIM-3, for example,
all indicators of activated T cells.
And so under normal conditions, our T cells can respond to
antigen and do their thing in
terms of killing. Under the obese state, a very
different signature,
where we have TCF7, CD62L,
KLF2, and CCR7, all indicators of a
non-activated, naive T cell state, unable
to kill those tumor cells. And again, mice that
were obese but then were brought back to normal weight
with the tirzepatide, we reversed this
immunosuppressive state, and right back to where the
controls were in terms of these markers, again, back to an activated CD8
T cell state. So one side of the coin is this
activation
ability of these T cells. The other is the antigen presentation, and we
were able to look at 18 different antigen presentation
gene sets.
This is primarily from the single-cell sequencing data.
And you see obesity is suppressing--
Actually, 18 out of those 18 gene sets were indicating
suppression by obesity. That was rescued by the tirzepatide.
So again, both sides of the coin now back to where they can function
as they should. So to summarize,
we know under obesity kind of driven conditions,
excess body weight, excess adiposity, and these metabolic
perturbations that are occurring, hyperglycemia, elevated insulin,
IGF-1, leptin.
From the standpoint of the TAM,
that state draws then a sort of picture of decreased antigen
presentation, decreased T cell activation, and oxidative
phosphorylation, which is actually a very good marker of the M2-like switch.
So that's the sort of condition pushed by obesity, pushing these
cells into that kind of pro-tumor
TAM state. On the CD8 TIL side, these are
hyporesponsive T cells under this condition.
We see kind of more stem-like markers, naive,
sort of non-progenitor
indicators.
So that's that naive, kind of immature, unable
to really kind of
kill and do their job. And so under this condition,
you see accelerated tumor growth.
However, tirzepatide seems to be reversing this. We get normalized weight.
The pair feeding data would tell us that much of the effect is through that
normalization of weight and reduction in adiposity.
Hyperglycemia is reversed. We've got normalized levels of insulin,
IGF-1, and leptin. Now we see the TAMs functioning like a TAM.
Increased antigen presentation is occurring.
You see the ability to activate T cells.
Oxidative phosphorylation is down in this case, and again, that's a marker of the
M1A light switch that occurs. From the
T cell side, now we've got increased T cell activation.
They're able to go through all the way to exhaustion, as in
that cycle that we're learning is really important for control of
tumors.
Decreased in the naive kind of markers that
we saw with the obesity. Now we've got a tumor
where there's a lot of death going on in terms of tumor production,
tumor
state, and tumor control underway.
Now, so that's where we are with some of the preclinical
data. There's a lot of unanswered questions still, and some we're
trying to address. Particularly, so, if we're
normalizing some of these systemic factors, which ones are really
driving
the picture here? Insulin, IGF, leptin is where we started.
So, we've kind of ruled out IGF-1. We think leptin
seems to be the more immunologically interesting side of this,
and maybe within the tumor microenvironment,
maybe having some of these kind of immune regulatory effects.
Insulin, probably complementing it as well.
So we're underway with that.
We were asked, actually, again, by the reviewers, what evidence do we have that
there's a causal connection between the effects on CD8 T cells
that we're seeing in actual tumor development and growth?
And so one approach was to knock out, basically
ablate, the CD8 T cells. And this will be the last data
I'll show you, but we repeated the experiment basically, again, with that low-fat
control, never obese, diet-induced obese mice
receiving tirzepatide or continuing on their obese group.
So, similar all the way until at this point we introduced either an
IgG antibody or anti-CD8 antibody to
ablate those CD8 T cells and then carried on, in this case, with the
MC38 model and just as before.
So under the IgG conditions, again, just as we had been saying,
obesity inducing tumor growth,
increasing that significantly, reversed by the tirzepatide nicely.
However, in the anti-CD8 group, where those T cells are
ablated,
no effect of tirzepatide. In fact, everybody's up with the controls.
You'll note, everybody's up over one
gram tumors, even the control group.
So it indicates that, yeah, there's sort of a T cell dependency on
this effect that we're seeing.
So some take-home messages, obesity, an established risk and progression factor
for many types of cancer. As Jennifer shared, CR, bariatric
surgery can reverse the pro-cancer effects of obesity, but there
are challenges there, and probably may not be scalable at a
population level. Certainly, the surgery side isn't.
The GLP-1s do seem to be a promising way to prevent or
intercept
obesity-related cancers. We're three for three, and
there's some other data. There's a pancreatic study out
with retatrutide, which is a triple.
It adds glucagon, basically, to the GLP-1 and GIP
from Eliza Makowski's group. So,
I think there's a consistent story emerging that these drugs may
be
effective. But again, the current epi and clinical data, I think,
is a bit limited. So the preclinical, I think,
is going to fill in some of these gaps.
And so we're seeing sustained weight loss, metabolic
reprogramming, anti-cancer effects consistently thus
far.
And that these anti-cancer actions appear to be dependent on both
the metabolic reversal of obesity effects as well
as the suppression of the CD8 T cell.
The ability to reverse that seems to be the key thing.
Many unanswered questions still, and I look forward to the discussion coming up.
So here's the group that did the work at UNC Chapel Hill and
my collaborators. Thank you very much. Looking forward to further discussion.
I think we can get one question.
Thanks for the great talk. So you know the Lilly data,
right? Tolza plus anti-IL-17
for psoriatic arthritis. It's so beautiful clinical
effect for psoriatic arthritis patients.
So for cancer, basically, we go other
total opposite way. So, your animal data is
quite very interesting. So M2 macrophage, CD8
activation. So is there any data in patients?
Like there are some M2 upregulation,
CD depletion, but in obese patient in
any cancer? Yeah.
So is there any indication that the-
Any clinical evidence? You said it is-
Yes
... very limited. Is any
patient
baseline, they have M2
upregulation, and after
treatment, M2 reverse to M1,
and it's something like that?
There is some data on that. We tried, but I decided not to
include it because it's just a little bit preliminary, but we took a signature, a
M2 and CD8 kind of signature that we got from the animal data
and applied it to TCGA data and saw it
was really protective in that. So we're working
through that. That's kind of the last piece on this paper we're adding, is to have
a human piece.
But there is support that, yes,
if we're able to rescue that M2 to the M1
and get the CD8 T cells going, that that's going to be a
protective manner. Yep. Thank you.
Thank you.
So maybe just one more question. There's a
A panel at the end, so if you have questions, you can come back.
But yeah, go ahead.
I don't know if this is more suitable for the panel then.
My ignorance, is there any effects on circulating T cells and
circulating immune cells, or is it all in the tumor?
Our data suggests this is a tumor microenvironment issue.
We compared splenic versus tumor microenvironment
T cells and did not see this. So
our data pushes us in the direction of this is a local
event in the tumor.
But leptin is a circulating measurement.
Leptin is circulating. Yeah, you're right.
We haven't quite reconciled that, but these--
Yeah, thanks.
Great. Thanks, Steve.
So I'm going to be the last presenter, and hope my
talk is still going to be interesting.
So I'm actually going to talk about some of the real-world evidence data
generated from our studies,
kind of covering both sort of cancer risk, as well as
survival outcomes.
But before getting to the actual study, I want to remind
everyone
what real-world data is and what real-world evidence are.
Both FDA in the United States and the EMA in Europe have been
pushing for these real-world evidence programs,
basically using this real-world evidence to actually approve new
indications, rather than waiting on the clinical trial
results. So this data are typically the data that's related
to patient health status, and those are collected through routine
care. So it's noisy, it has issues,
but it complement randomized clinical
trials where a lot of the
experiments are controlled, which is good in terms of rigor and
causal relationship, but sometimes have the generalizability
issues because the patient population in your trial are going to be
very different to some degree on the patient that you actually treat.
So that's one. The
FDA and the EMA actually have some guidance on how to evaluate
applications of real-world evidence.
So from a FDA perspective, they have a three-part approach where
they really focus on whether the specific real-world data you are
using actually fit for use in terms of data quality, in terms
of data capturing. And then the second piece is more about
your study design. Even if it's an epidemiology
observational study, you still have to follow a rigorous study design,
and there's some requirement there.
And the last piece is really on how the study are conducted when you actually
design-- After you design it, how you actually conduct them in terms of reporting,
in terms of monitoring.
I'm going to skip the data quality piece a little bit,
but I'm really just going to
talk about
the study design piece. Everyone here, a lot of you
obviously know what the bias is inherently in the
observational data. Obviously, comparing to a randomized
clinical trial, you don't have a lot of the tools that you have in RCTs.
Randomization obviously is not a thing,
and the study protocols and some of the other rigor
in RCTs are not obviously in the
observational data. But we cannot
really do all of this in real-world data, but at least we have a way
to standardize the protocol, think about statistic methods to
mitigate some of the
biases. So one thing that we've been doing quite a bit,
this is actually named specifically, if you look at EMA guidance,
it's actually recommended by EMA when you actually generate real-world
evidence. FDA's language is a little bit vague,
but they're using it as an example.
So target trial emulation kind of offer a
structural framework to emulate a hypothetical clinical
trial. So you're designing your study as you are designing clinical
trials, then really focus on the seven
components of clinical trial, right?
So what is the eligibility of your cohort?
What is the target population you are targeting?
How the treatments are being assigned.
Obviously, in observational data, you don't have randomization.
So how is it going to be assigned? How you define time zero
actually going to lead to a lot of the bias mitigation
strategies. What is the procedure?
What are the primary and secondary outcomes of interest?
If you look at some historical epidemiology studies, oftentimes, we
don't really talk about what is primary and secondary outcomes.
What is the follow-up period? In RCTs, the typical follow-up
period,
no observational study, but it's typically one to three years.
In epidemiology study in the past, oftentimes just not specified.
What is the causal contrast? Is this intention to treat?
Is this sort of per protocol? Do
you per protocol study in real-world data?
It's doubtful, right? Adherence is not easy to measure.
But for safety outcomes, you want to do as treated and how you actually define the
outcome events. And the analysis plan, obviously, needs to be
comprehensive, and think about not just the confounding, not just
the immortal time biases, but also what is the residual
confounding? How do you measure it?
What is your methods of doing diagnostics and all that?
So systematically think about it.
Itself is not a causal inference method.
It's really a framework to help you think about these strategies.
And our group have done a lot of the study.
I actually have a figure which is now in
this version. We've done a lot of target trial emulation studies in the
past three or four years, and a lot of them are focusing on
GLP-1I'm a data scientist. Cancer is one of
my areas. We've actually evaluated GLP-1 against
Parkinson's disease, against Alzheimer's disease, and
against a number of other
outcomes. And just spoiler, we actually see
pretty strong effect in terms of a protective effect on
cancer, on Parkinson's, and Alzheimer's.
Those are published in JAMA series, JAMA Neurology,
and obviously JAMA Oncologies.
Before we dig into a lot of the
GLP-1 and cancer studies, we actually started by doing a
meta-analysis
of GLP-1 drugs. Actually, it's not just GLP-1, but we also
look at
other, the new classes of glucose-lowering drugs like
DPP and SGLT2 in terms of sort of the
comparators.
We did analysis on 26 trials,
enrolled about 200,000 participants across six
organ systems. But as you can see from this figure, we actually
don't really have strong signals whether it's protective or
not
if you look at the cancer piece. You see a little bit
signal when you're looking at GLP-1 against SGLT2 on
trial cancer,
but a lot of those are inconclusive.
So that's kind of led us to did three series
of studies. Two of them are looking
at cancer risk, and one of them is looking at survival
outcomes on patients who survived cancer.
And again, there are different strengths and weakness of different data
sources. Two of them are done on the
Medicare population within the United States.
Obviously, it's limited.
Medicare doesn't cover GLP-1 for weight loss,
so we are studying it in type 2 diabetes population.
And then the last study that we did is on a general EHR
cohort, where we're actually comparing GLP-1 against
non-users, and in the general obesity population.
So the first thing I'm going to talk about are the GLP-1
having varying effects on cancer risks
of two studies, as I already kind of alluded to.
One study is using the 15% random sample of national
Medicare fee-for-service beneficial covering 2016 and
2020, which you obviously see there's a lag.
I mean, a lot of the drugs are not
coming out until 2021 or 2022.
In this
data set, we are actually looking at type 2 diabetes population with or
without obesity. And then the second study is on
the EHR study. The OneFlorida Cancer Research Consortium is,
if you're in the United States, you probably heard about the PCORnet, which is
a PCORI-funded clinical data research networks.
Nationally, there are eight of them, cover about 140 million
patients across the United States. OneFlorida is one of those network.
OneFlorida covers about 21 million patient population
across six states,
and 15 different healthcare organizations.
Ten of them are in Florida, covers about 18
million population in Florida, and then five out of the states.
And for this data set, for this study, we used data from 2014
to 2024, and we study obesity patients with and
without type 2 diabetes.
So this is the Medicare type 2 diabetes cohort.
We're looking at GLP-1 against nine cancer types,
and because we have different sort of data assets,
we actually started with 5% random sample and then moved to
10% and then 15. So we actually have to do some data merging.
And we also compare GLP-1 against
SGLT2, and DPP4
because this is a type 2 diabetes cohort, so we needed some active
comparators.
As you can see, at the end,
when we looking at GLP-1 against SGLT2,
we got a cohort about 86,000. When we
look at GLP-1 against DPP4, we got a much bigger
cohort, 170,000, 180,000 patient
populations.
And the result is
overall non-significant if you're looking at
GLP-1 against SGLT2 on the nine cancers
that we compared.
But we did see a little bit of signal in the kidney cancer.
So there's sort of an increased risk
when you're looking at GLP-1 user against SGLT2 in
kidney cancer. So it's not all benefits.
There's a potential risk as well, so we really have to think about that as
well.
And when we're looking at GLP-1 against DPP4,
very similar result in terms of
overall cancer incidence. It doesn't have any different effect,
but this time it's a little bit different.
There's sort of an increased risk for endometrial cancer when you
compare GLP-1 with DPP4. But
it's sort of borderline. The sample size is not huge, so
just take it as a grain of salt. So that's one.
And in the EHR study,
in the obesity cancer, we look at GLP-1 against
14 different cancer. Thirteen of them are
obesity-related,
based on CDC andNCI definition, we did throw
in lung cancer,
partially because of my own interest in lung cancer, partially it is
related to some of the mechanism, looking at
GLP-1, and specifically the insulin line.
In this study, we explicitly designed
the target trial.
So obviously retrospective, we covered the data from
2014 to 2024, and then we're looking
at adults only who are on anti-obesity
medication. So if you look at the indication for approved
GLP-1 use, it's either obese or you have
a slightly higher BMI of
27, I think, and then you have some of the higher risk factors.
So we included all of that. And in this one, we're actually looking at
GLP-1 against non-users.
For mitigating some of the biases, we actually did a time-dependent
propensity score matching because some of the time-varying effects
exposures.
So at the end, we identified 43,000 cohort
that we use after matching. And the result is
somewhat interesting. If you're looking at the overall cancer incidence,
I think it's protective, 0.83.
If you're looking at specific subtype of cancer, it's protective
against endometrial cancer, ovarian cancer,
and meningioma.
But it does have a borderline
increased risk of kidney cancer. If you remember our
Medicare population on type 2 diabetes, the signal is much
stronger, but the signal is still consistent.
But again, this is a different cohort. It's not a type 2 diabetes cohort.
And this result is actually consistent with some of
the other studies that we've done on other diseases,
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's, where we actually see a significant heterogeneous
treatment effect across several populations.
And then the last study I'm going to talk about is in the survivorship.
And the spoiler alert is it does improve survival in cancer
survivors with type 2 diabetes compared to
SGLT2 and DPP4. Because this is a Medicare population,
that's the comparator we have.
If you look at the results, when we compare GLP-1 with
DPP4,
the effect is much stronger.
It's not a huge cohort. We only have
2,500 patients that we actually
identify
from the 5% random sample of Medicare.
But the other thing I want to
point you all to is sort of the subgroups.
So,
the protective effect is across all age groups,
and
when you're looking at
gender differences, sex differences, and I think either-- I think
Jennifer also alluded to some of the effects are different
by sex. We also see that effect in the
studies. And then the protective effect is more pronounced in
non-Hispanic whites. Partially, obviously,
there's socioeconomic status issues, and the sample size is different.
But in a lot of the other studies that we've done, that is pretty
consistent.
And then when you're looking at different cancer types, breast
cancer is most pronounced
in terms of protective effect.
And when we're actually looking at GLP-1 against
SGLT2,
there's actually no significant effect.
And even in subgroup analysis, it's very
consistent. There's no differences.
And this result is actually consistent with our GLP-1
and Parkinson disease study. The effect
of GLP-1 against DPP4, which is the older class,
is more pronounced
between SGLT2. And
it's sort of a side story, not directly cancer relevant,
but it's more about Parkinson disease.
MJ Fox Foundation and QDPD, which is in Europe, they
actually founded a number of clinical trial, phase 2 trials
across the international space,
looking at these different GLP-1 classes and how it's going
to help with
Parkinson progression, which is different than our endpoints.
And none of the study actually is significant.
So there's no significant effect of GLP-1 on
Parkinson
progression.
Our
real-world study, again, is different.
It's in type 2 diabetes population.
It's protective with
high significance. And the other insights from that study is
actually the more potent the recent generation of
GLP-1, when you're looking at semaglutide and tirzepatide,
it's more pronounced in those. So obviously, neurodegenerative
disease is different than cancer.
The
end of that story is we're actually designing
newer phase 2 clinical trials, multi-site,
looking at a specific subpopulation and more
potent GLP-1. Maybe some of that, some of the direction we can
look at in the cancer space as well.
So I think that's all my-- oh, and the takeaway message is
RCT has RCT limitation, real-world data have real-world data
limitations. So we probably want to really think about it.
And one potential way isMaybe not every
single cancer type. We probably can look at from preclinical
studies as well as real-world evidence studies on
specific sub-cancer types, because obviously, RCT is going to be very
expensive. You're not going to be able to afford all of those trials.
We do see a little bit increased risk on kidney
cancer. We have some unpublished
data as well on different real-world evidence data,
and the spoiler is actually some of the signal actually gets flipped
across subtypes. So we really have to think about what that
is. The story on GLP-1 and survivor,
it's more clear for us right now. So, obviously more
study is needed. I think I can take one question and then invite all the
panelists up to the stage.
Yes.
Yeah. Thanks for the great talk. So my question is like GLP-1a
and the SGLT2 inhibitor. These two show
great efficacy to decrease CKD, right?
So why the difference between
GLP-1a versus SGLT2 for cancer? And also,
another question for SGLT2
versus GLP-1RA for type 2
diabetes patient. So do you have data GLP-1a
versus non-treated? Because that's more
important, because in your obesity cohort is GLP-1a
was non-treated.
Yeah.
So that show some increased
kidney cancer risk, right?
Yeah.
But since that GLP-1,
what SGLT2 is kind of not-
Right
... direct comparison.
Right.
So, why
GLP-1a decrease CKD, but increase
kidney cancer, right? And there's some conflict.
I just try to find some linkage between CKD, cancer,
increase rate, obesity, this cancer.
Yeah, because your
cancer patient kind of body weight mostly is low, right?
Mm-hmm.
So quite different. So, what's the underlying
mechanism for all this? Yeah.
Yeah. Thanks for the question. So that means for our data, there's no difference
between GLP-1 and SGLT2-
Mm-hmm
...
at least for cancer survivors pieces.
We have some ongoing studies that actually look at
active and non-users.
It's just not ready to be presented.
That's where I'm actually saying some of the
signal actually flipped across subtypes.
Yeah.
The kidney cancer question,
probably I need to ask Steve for help on what the mechanism of that.
It is more pronounced in type 2 diabetes.
It may be related to some of the damage already done in that patient population.
And in the general population, we actually don't see that being significant.
It's on the borderline, and the sample size is very small.
But I think this is a good time, actually, invite all the other speakers and maybe
have a discussion.
So maybe we can start there. Steve, what's your
thought about the kidney piece, the kidney cancer and the CKD?
Yeah. Thanks, Yang.
My interpretation is what you just said, that the susceptibility of a
type 2 diabetic to-
Mm-hmm
... kidney issues is. So I think it's amplifying maybe.
You maybe not see it in a
non-type 2 diabetic, but it may be amplifying what is
underlying in a-
Yeah
... type 2 diabetic.
Okay.
I think there's some
ocular issues, too,
that shows up in type 2 diabetics. Not cancer related,
so I think it's enhancing whatever is in the
background.
Okay.
That was a great series of talks. I guess, Dr.
Bian, you talked about this at the end, but I was wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about what types of GLP-1 RAs these patients were
on. Were they mostly on liraglutide and the older
generation? And is there a way to separate that out currently from the
Medicaid/Medicare data?
Yes, it's separable, but if you remember, the
Medicare data that we use is up to 2020, so you're not going
to see semaglutide and tirzepatide.
So it would be early generation, like liraglutide, larotide, and those kind of
early generation. So we are actually actively updating the
data and actually see some of the new things.
And obviously, Lilly has the new triple agonists, which
we're not going to see any data at all probably for another two or three
years.
There are also data that have been published from the TriNetX database that
have looked a little bit at different-
Mm-hmm
... some of the newer versus older.
I think what's hard is that there are now a lot of these observational
analyses out there, and the data are really different in each of
them. So I think it really does make it complicated.
I think one of the other things we have to think about from the real-world data is
that there are reasons why a physician would prescribe one
drug versus another, which may drive some of these things, too.
There are drugs that are used earlier in the trajectory of diabetes,
and then people start to be on an increasing number of agents as the
diabetes kind of gets more significant and insulin resistance
increases that really may impact some of these findings, that
just make it hard. I think that this is the data that we have at this
point, but it is not consistent often, and it makes it really
hard to know what to think of this.
The SGLT2 data is really intriguing.
Your point about what do you compare it to, I guess, is the
question. And so there was an early study with 13
obesity-associated cancers that showed relative to insulin-In
a type 2 diabetic, the GLP-1s were dynamite for the
most part. But when you compare it to, I can't remember what the comparison was,
but it might have been DPP4.
Metformin, even.
It might have been Metformin, yeah. There was no effect.
But I'm wondering if your SGLT2 data is telling us that maybe
SGLT2 is pretty promising for-
Yeah
...
I haven't seen it much in terms of a sort of an
agent for cancer prevention, but-
Yeah. Not on cancer, but at least the Parkinson's space,
we're actually saying that SGLT2 may be a different thing.
Maybe it's as useful as GLP-1.
So that's kind of where we're going too.
And then the other thing I was going to talk about real world data that Jennifer
really posed, and there are also other issues, for example,
combination therapy, which are you going to actually look at?
And then compound that you just get without a prescription.
So how you're actually looking at those are very different too.
I'm really interested.
Do we really want people on the GLP-1s for their life
or what do we
begin to transition off? And I wonder if SGLT2 is a candidate.
I actually need medical advice. So I'm actually a living patient of
GLP-1, and I'm actually thinking about how do I
transition off. I actually tried. It didn't work.
Oh, they-
I have to get back.
Gain the weight back. We have a lot of questions.
Oh, sorry. Yeah. Maybe...
So do you think medical oncologists would be hesitant to
give a GLP-1 receptor agonist to patient who
historically were obese, maybe are still overweight, but
they already see that they're losing weight, which most cancer patients do.
They're already losing appetite.
Do you think as a medical oncologist, because you are one, you would be
hesitant to prescribe them GLP-1 receptor agonists?
Well, so a couple of things. One, in terms of the
weight loss that people with cancer experience, we don't
see that as much anymore. People do tend to lose weight when
they have advanced disease, and I would caution that none of these
data address anything about advanced disease at all.
Even if we're looking at outcomes, really, the
connection between excess adiposity and poor outcomes is in people with
early-stage disease. I would not give GLP-1s to a
patient with advanced disease. I think the other thing is, these are not easy drugs
to prescribe. If you don't
ramp them up correctly and pay attention to symptoms and things like that,
people do very poorly on them. And then when you look at a lot of these databases,
a lot of people start them and stop them.
And so I would really, as a medical oncologist, I have a hard time keeping up
with all the millions of new therapies for breast cancer that you all hear about at
this meeting. I would not prescribe them personally.
I would send patients to an expert that really knows how to ramp them.
That being said, patients are buying them themselves and doing all kinds of things
with them. But I don't think at this point we're at a place where oncologists
in general would be doing this as part of their routine practice.
For example, I work on pancreatic cancer, which gets detected very
late, right? So when we were speaking to a medical oncologist
about that, they were like, "We would be so hesitant to prescribe that to a
pancreatic cancer patient."
Yeah. Especially, the data we have now, I would not consider
this something that I would prescribe to a patient.
Mm. That's what I thought.
I think a related question is, a patient comes in and they're on the drugs,
and
do you take them off or not? And so that must come up a lot, I would guess.
That comes up a lot. And I think it kind of depends on a lot of things.
Why is the patient taking the drug?
Certainly, if they're taking it for diabetes, I would be very hesitant to consider
that. But I think that,
just because we are in the midst of an enormous real-world experiment,
people stay on the drugs. There are people writing up their experiences of people
staying on the drugs. I think it can be hard for people that are having nausea to
be receiving concurrent chemotherapy, and I have a lot of my patients who are on
them that decide to stop them during chemotherapy.
But we don't really know the right answer to that at this point.
Right. So we have a lot of questions. So, let me set a rule.
Left, right, left, right.
Yeah. Sort of in that vein, I had a question for Dr.
Herzing about if you could talk about
how tirzepatide might affect initiation versus progression of the
tumor. So I'm wondering if you repeated that treatment where disease
burden is already a bit higher, if it would
induce the tumor microenvironment and
result in
regression. And yeah, just how you all view this as a preventative
versus therapeutic approach.
Yeah. The data I showed mostly was interception today.
We're introducing tumor cells,
and looking at tirzepatide effects there.
In our endometrial work, that's a genetically engineered mouse model,
so we're able to look at early versus late events.
And I will say, most of
the picture looks like it's more the progression.
It's the metabolic changes and driving
progression. We're not seeing really much in terms of early
carcinogenesis, tumor genesis
events occurring. So I would say the bulk of our data, at least thus
far, is that it's a more progression metabolic
reprogram kind of issue.
Thank you.
Yeah. Thanks.
Hi. I want to point out from viewing the stage, I'm on the left, not
the right.
So I'm very interested in your results.
It sounds like you're talking a lot, particularly in your animal studies,
about metabolic health-
Yes
... and disruptions of metabolic regulation.
And many of the markers that you
reported on are also markers that go into
biological aging clocks.
Yes.
Something like GrimAge 2 has many of your markers.
And have you thought about this in the context of, especially when you're talking
about dysregulated immune function of an
accelerated aging syndrome, where metabolic
aging disruptions are interacting with other pillars of aging,
and that the GLPs are reversing
some of that in certain pathways like you mentioned for immune
function?
Yeah, thanks.I share your enthusiasm for that
sort of aging-related
and how obesity seems to mimic a lot of the aging-related
metabolic and inflammatory immune effects.
So,
we're interested in that and have seen that
obesity really does, and the combination, if you do
the same models I talked about, if you do those in an obese
20-month-old mouse,
the combination is terrible. Those are the most
aggressive tumors I think we've ever seen.
So there's definitely something there, and the tirzepatide does seem to be
reversing that. Is there a point at which
I'm too old, I guess is the question.
I worry about that, and we're trying to design some studies to look at that.
Is the effect truly
independent of age or not? I kind of doubt it.
I think at some point, the responses are going to be
differential. But yeah, I would say
our data, at least in our models, is saying that it's mostly the
metabolic change that's driving the effects.
And so metabolic health, critical, and that's probably why we're seeing these drugs
protective across a variety of diseases.
So thank you for that.
Please.
Hey, thank you for a very interesting presentation, all of you.
I wanted to
maybe add some information.
Why you see different results for kidney cancer than for other
cancer. A new mechanism that was published
in March linking obesity with cancer is
hypoplasia. When your
body grows, your organ grows in response, and
actually 60% of the increase in kidney
size due to obesity is due to more cells
in the
proximal convoluted tubule. That is where 75% of
kidney cancers arise. So that might be
irreversible, so you're not seeing that protection with the weight loss that you
might see from other cancers.
So that was just-
That's interesting. Thank you. That's very interesting. Did not know that.
No.
Please.
Hi, I'm Jessica Rampy. I'm a postdoc at Vanderbilt, and my question has to do
with thyroid cancer.
So I think GLP-1 receptor agonists have gotten a bad rap in terms of
thyroid cancer because of the preclinical studies with medullary thyroid cancer
risk.
Right.
But weight loss is actually really beneficial for thyroid
function and reduces thyroid-stimulating hormone levels and
increases thyroid hormone levels.
So could you talk about how GLP-1 receptor agonists maybe modulate
thyroid cancer risk, progression,
and aggression?
Thank you.
Yeah, thanks.
I was pleased in your real-world data that
thyroid cancer risk is not showing up, and that's
been consistent across literature.
So I share your-- I think that's a rat
function that
hopefully that black box will be taken off of these
relatively soon.
I think what's complicated, obviously there's lots of different kinds of thyroid
cancer, and medullary thyroid cancers are not as common as
some. So, I think that there are specific patients with
familial syndromes that they've kind of steered away from taking them based
on the--
But the thyroid findings have varied.
If you look across all of these observational studies, there are
100% some that show an increased risk of thyroid cancer and some that don't,
and I suspect that it kind of depends on what the thyroid
cancers are. So I don't know that we have enough information at
this point to just say there's no risk.
Okay.
But,
again, it's not seen in every study.
So we're technically over time, but I think we can still, if you
guys are interested in answering the three questions, we can-
Well, I don't-- Do they need the room?
Do they need the room? They need the room.
Quick questions, quick answers.
Yes.
Hi, I'm Liza Makowski, and I wanted to give a shout-out.
On Tuesday, we have a session with NCI on metabolic dysregulation
and cancer risk program, and actually, Steve Hursting is on our
external advisory board. And so that's where we're looking at risk
in patients and mice. And I just wanted to ask about the kind
of new initiatives using NAMs. So these
kind of moving away from mouse models and the struggles when we know that
obesity affects so many different parts of the body, as
we heard today, circulating or local and normal tissue versus
tumor-associated. So how do you suggest we navigate in
this new environment when obesity really affects
microbiome, everything? How do we address some of the
needs now?
I think really strong justifications when they come asking has
been my response.
Mm-hmm.
Although I say that, we're probably doing more so culture
and co-cultures and those sorts of things than
we would've been otherwise.
Mm-hmm.
And I've
got a collaboration with a Drosophila
colleague.
And Drosophila, they don't have GLP-1 receptors, but they've got something like it
and-
Oh, cool.
So there's some probably humanizing steps that we're beginning with to
explore that.
That's more a hobby than anything at this point, but-
It looks like they do need a room, so-
Okay
... let's take the rest of the question offline.
We'll chat about that because that's a big deal.
I'm going to put a last plug as well.
There's an American Cancer Society and CIUK conference
in June, so if you're interested in that, please attend.
Oh, let's take the question offline. Yep.
My question is about the adiposity.
Can we-
Adiposity is increasing the-
You come on the stage, and we can just do-
What is the adiposity's influence on the tumor
microenvironment and the metabolism of the cancer?
How is the adiposity in the other organs shifting
the metabolisms of the cancer cell?
I'm going to come to you.